Physicists have discovered yet another form
of matter: excitonium!
The new discovery has them all very ecstatic.
If Julian was here that pun would have made
you unsubscribe.
Excitonium is pretty exciting, because this
is a discovery 50 years in the making.
That’s when excitonium was first theorized,
but proving it existed has been a bit tricky
because it looked remarkably like another
kind of electron movement called a Peierls
phase.
Basically, it’s all about how the electrons
move around the nucleus, but don’t get too
electrified, let’s back up a second.
Thanks to new measurement techniques, excitonium’s
existence has been conclusively demonstrated.
So now we know it exists, but what exactly
is it?
Excitonium is a condensate, a collection of
particles that exhibit quantum phenomena like
superconductivity or superfluidity on a macroscopic
scale.
The particles that make up excitonium are,
naturally, called excitons.
Excitons are bosons, the category of particles
that includes such hits as the photon, the
gluon, and of course the higgs-boson.
Now tilt your head back because here comes
the part that will make your brain melt and
dribble out your nose.
Excitons are composite particles.
A composite particle is something made up
of two or more elementary particles.
But, with excitons it’s actually not that
simple.
They’re made up of an electron that has
jumped to a higher energy level from the crowded
outermost shell of an atom, AND the HOLE that
electron left behind.
The other electrons in that crowded shell
make the hole behave as though it were a particle
with a positive charge, and the hole attracts
the escaped electron back like it’s coaxing
a runaway dog home with a treat.
When the two are reunited, they form an exciton.
If an electron combining with the empty space
it left behind to make a new particle makes
perfect sense to you, then congratulations
on your future as a particle physicist.
For the rest of us, it’s just one more example
of how the quantum world is as intuitive as
Windows 8.
But don’t fret, even physicists aren’t
totally sure what excitonium will actually
do.
Before it was discovered it was argued that
it would act like a superfluid, a perfect
conductor, or an insulator.
Now, that we’ve finally found it we can
figure out which argument was right, and what
it could actually be used for.
If particle physics excites you then subscribe
for more videos, like this one on Quantum
teleportation.
And if you’re not aren’t excited enough,
just wait and see our upcoming show Seeker
Plus!!!!
(AHH finally I know) Come join me and some
guests as we deep dive into conversations
about the science subjects we love most.
Subscribe so you don't miss it,
and thanks for watching Seeker!